uh this hotel has a restaurant
built into it so i know that a lot of
people who are in quarantine have really
bad food options but ours is basically
like five-star hotel food so while you
do have the option to uber eats some
people had problems like getting the
food to their room where there were too
many orders or whatever
i'm not going to because i've had like
just
amazing meals already better than i
would eat at home i'm like i'll just
stay in the hotel
this is fine yeah what's the uh
what's the you are totally
required to stay in your room right
correct no window no balcony not even
allowed to go into the hallway
no window or balcony well i have the
window but it doesn't open
so yeah no fresh error oh okay but i get
that but but
i thought you were saying that you're
not allowed to take advantage of that
like if you had a balcony they would say
no going out there no if you had if you
had a balcony you'd be allowed
um and i have asthma right now and
perpetually every time i wake up
um or every time i try to exercise which
you know happens half the time anyway
but
i always get asthma in hotels and they
said if it's really bad that they could
move me to a hotel that has a balcony
because that would help
but i'm going to try to avoid it because
that like is probably in a lot of cases
used for people who have more serious
conditions than me or like you know i
brought enough medication that i
i should be fine uh what would happen if
you just went rogue and just went
wandering in the hallway
it's a fine i think it's two thousand
dollars i think
you get fined even if you open the door
without a mask on so
they deliver your food they knock on the
door
and then you have to wait 30 seconds put
a mask on and grab whatever they left
for you
um and i also got like delivery
yesterday from my
dad sent some flowers and my aunts and
some snacks uh but all of that stuff is
like you have to be really careful about
opening the door
and i'm always so conscious of like how
far i step out
like other cameras like how um but
nobody's allowed in this room ever
either except that today at some point i
will get
covered tested and they have to do that
in the doorway
but you still have to put your mask on
while you open the door so
it's uh it's all right it's fine you
know i've got
my xbox series s here because it's the
light one
and i've got my oculus here which is how
i'm exercising
um my razer laptop's got a i think it's
got a 3080 in it
runs games just fine so in the grand
scheme of things
it's all right but i am only on day two
i wonder if anybody is it'll get worse i
wonder if anybody's opened any um
like speakeasy hotels that you know
enforce all these rules in the front
side and then the back side have like
secret doors that open and lead to like
an underground network of
nightclubs and stuff i can pay people
off to just let me walk up and down the
hallway a little bit
yeah exactly yeah it's uh
yeah i mean it's pretty much guaranteed
anytime there's something that's sort of
like severely
uh legally enforced there is invariably
like an incentive created to create the
black market version of that thing so
i'm just
thinking about like what the hotel the
pop-up hotels
uh industry is looking like right now in
australia definitely some of the people
that i got here with
um because we're all in the same flight
um really empty flight
we're like pissed off there was one guy
who kept being like this is like a
[ __ ] prison sentence i haven't done
anything wrong
like nobody said you did buddy it's okay
we're trying not to kill all the old
people
that's a weird thing that he would i
it's as if it
caught him by surprise and he didn't
know fully in advance that this was the
protagonist of the universe austin what
we didn't realize is uh this is his
story
um it sounds a lot like we were talking
about troy though
are we are we talking about how
president mccomb
formerly senator mccomb could have yes
easily gone okay
so i'm tracking immediately i didn't
know what you're talking about and then
there's two things that you don't or the
one thing about physics that everybody
understands
the same matter cannot occupy the same
space at the same time that is a lot
exactly thank you troy this is why we
have you on the show he's just he keeps
up
you know austin are you okay
you look you look poorly why did you
shave too it's weird
don't do that i have to liberate my skin
periodically yeah
it's like it's it's it's uh
it's not good when when i want to put
austin in the front basket of a bicycle
and ride him towards his people
wow you want to ride me towards my
people
that's that's an easy thing
and uh nope nope instantly sounds
alana i've already missed the thing
about you been in a different place you
have and you missed out now
um i'm jumping straight to the content
that i never get to jump to
which is that i believe everyone
has played returnal
oh yeah [ __ ] sake austin i'm trying to
have a video game
but after i played miles morales i
played uh i played your certainly
i've been on the cutting edge by playing
a game released in 2007.
okay so we've got miles morales adorning
myself
do you think do you think that that uh
they they just looked at their
uh their launch window for eternal and
went
[ __ ] or do you think they were like ah
we're fine
in terms of what i think they probably
benefit from the space
it feels like a really great place for a
team like house mark
no what came out resident evil but like
well no rezzy's still hot
and then you also have mass effect
mass effect's a different crowd though i
think but it does interesting isn't it
for the same space for those games no i
think i think it's fine
i don't well okay this this i'm going to
throw this that you talked about i think
it depends if you're thinking of it as a
small triple a or a big indie i think it
depends which angle you're coming
base it's time there there is everything
i always pushed against this when people
were like our competition is this like
your competition is time that's the only
thing you're competing with
because and and that means that like
that's actually period why not because
well because they're philosophical the
right way because there's there's
marketing is very targeted and specific
and it's like if i
as a throwing darts it's throwing darts
nobody knows
it's not a science nobody knows that's
true that's true
i would say i would say though there are
three i would say resident evil mass
effect
uh remastered right that's the name
right legendary master it's a remastered
legendary edition sorry it's been
legendary those are
three completely outside of people like
us who work in games and therefore have
to play everything i think your average
person on the street those are three
very different audiences who are playing
i agree and i also feel like
for those three games because they are
so different and so
differently satisfying i am jumping
between the three
of them for different reasons sure but
you are announcing
one snap nobody plays i mean
the best way you are you are in every
way and a lot
um did i
um it's a lana adjacent it's i mean most
people don't have the ability to do that
like there's the i i think this is
probably an accurate
at least estimate most oh you had a good
day
i had a very very good well it's my week
off you see this is my only
like appointment thing to do this week
i'm very sorry i'm having a great we're
barely an appointment
um oh it feels like it's sometimes no
it's good it's good it's been a nice
week
most people are hit gamers right so
they're going to play
it's for if for no other reason it's
either two things
that they're the most precious commodity
other time or money
most people now game pass is probably
going to change all that but most people
can only spend
that's true you know 60 70 quid or
whatever uh
at a time so they're like what am i
going to buy why'd you go with his
currency because i love him more than i
love you
i see that he's waiting to see what i
thought of his role in martial you're
great at miles morales by the way as
little aside genuinely loved that play
from you genuinely
here's nice here's i will tangent off of
myself
i cannot speak highly enough about the
insomniac team
um those guys best game feel people in
the business
dear god man they they're just
incredible the way that they brought me
into the team
is is super rare and and very much
appreciated and
they let me just own own that role and
own that space
i got to go in the whole uh leg day was
a total ad lib and normally people were
like
is that like a special i love that line
that's great literally done a leg
workout the day before like they can't
skip it
and they were like we're keeping that is
that cool i'm like is it cool
can we keep it um the uh you know the
cat in the backpack
yeah uh that cat is owned by somebody at
santa monica studio
what so yeah so like he's posted a bunch
of pictures like captured the
yeah or designed the oh that's great so
they posted a bunch of pictures in like
we had an animal slack like a pets of
sms slack
um i'm pretty sure his name's kevin and
it's like it's i'm like i know that cat
he's famous that is the best name
for i i like wanna call animals
by like proper names like this is
charles
and this is duck no char even charles's
to me is a little bit too
anthropomorphic or non-anthropomorphic
animalistic
anyway i i josh the cat
is great i right now i told pam's like i
need you to understand if we do get
another dog
i really want to call him toby ziegler
hmm
that's a specific kind of dog that's a
specific reason you're going to have to
go for together toby's eager
to be just like like a dash of neurotic
lovable affable but just big dopey
shout out to richard schiff um but i
like when i when i bought
returnal i was like oh here we go it's
69.99
or you can get the deluxe edition for
79.99 so like already and we saw this a
little bit for for free
back in dollars for those lists yeah
there you go i do the currency
consistency please
sorry no i think it's 70 quid here i
think it's like a 70 pound game i think
it's i think
i think it's imagine you think it's yeah
put a gun down mike you're blind it's
always the finger guys right this is
like yeah i'm a mysterious fella in
terms of my politics and opinions
i'm super broken
so i i think that you know we're
starting to see with this new console
generation we're starting to see like
it's
it's scaling right and i i feel like
most people are like dude i don't have
now pandemic people were like i don't i
can go to work
on zoom i can go to school on zoom and i
can probably get away with if i have a
ps5
or even if i have a ps4 i could probably
play more and i think that that we
probably saw a huge uptick in
not only installs but actual people
playing and time in
but my install rate is like high and my
my play time is low it it i'm here to
support the industry as best i can and
it certainly supports me
my steam library has become a museum of
releases
yeah but like really corridors
i don't want to know the number of how
many people have bought my games versus
played them like i think i've benefited
from i'm not playing any of that [ __ ]
what are you talking about
no why would you i honestly mike i am
100
install completion with your games
that is that that's very kind of you i
don't think you are probably
probably not the the model what is it
70 mike you might know this or a lot of
you might know this what's the
what's the average completion rate am i
if i know it or should i
yeah austin you don't know dude shut the
[ __ ] up not a good source for this
austin's finest today yeah have we
called attention you don't have a baby
i'm in the legendary edition of awesome
we'll get i will get to asking you about
austin that's our experience
the last that i uh read which was
way out of date completion rate for most
video games was more like 30
it's super low it is my third year but i
think that now you can
generally like you know you can see how
many people story campaign completion by
the way that not even like a hundred
percent
that'd be way less common seeing the end
credits yeah seeing end credits
i generally look at like the trophies or
achievements or whatever to see how many
what percentage of people have gotten
them because that's also a really good
indication of any secret achievements
which one's the next in the story or
whatever
but it drops off hot people do not
finish video games which
i always wonder why like i guess if you
just don't like it you run out of time
but for it to be that low and to spend
that much money on it is pretty
surprising to me
every time but uh sometimes you get to a
point though with games i find where you
you feel like you've
seen everything it's going to give you
and whether or not that's true or not
you don't know but like that's true i
definitely check out
games like sometimes early on even if
i'm enjoying it just because
is it fatigue is that what it is or is
it just i mean
i mean for me it's exactly it's the
thing you were talking about earlier
where and this is the unique position
all four of us are in where like because
i have to kind of play everything a
little bit usually just kind of get a
sense of where everything's at
if i feel like i've learned the lessons
from a game i'll move on if i feel like
i've seen what they're
what they're putting out i'll i'll
complete games like
to be clear like spider-man brilliant
game but like you could definitely play
the first
half of spider-man and you would know
most mechanics of what the game was
going to be yeah i enjoy that game so i
finish it but like most of the time when
i get to that mid point in a triple a
game where i've seen
where i start to notice like that oh
this is where you're used reusing that
geometry i saw in the first level okay
that's usually my sign to check out and
play something else but that's a again
very specific position we're in as
as as industry people i was told by
someone who i whose anonymity i will
protect but
you know developer in the aaa space that
they deliberately
on on a noteworthy title or i shouldn't
say deliberately but knowingly given
finite resources and time to ship the
game
they deliberately polished the first
half of the game quite a bit more
than the back half because of the
phenomenon we're talking about is that
common you think is that a i would
imagine that's not anonymous
or we can go deep like i can talk about
revelation schedules if you like i love
that it's a thing
talk about the ass asset revelation
scheduling so this is literally a thing
where
um if a game a game literally is like
10 things 500 things a million things
you're going to put in front of the
player
and you know you have x you know each
thing costs x amount of money you 100
your asset revelation schedule will
prioritize putting stuff at the front
rather than at the end it makes sense
it's very interesting
because of the phenomenon but b as well
because because there's a really
interesting phenomenon with
people playing games if you're playing a
single player campaign
about at the midpoint of most
single-player campaigns
they'll stop giving you new stuff
because what they know is
actually you're going to have new
interesting experiences past that point
because you're going to be finding
interesting combinations of the
mechanics they've given you so far
or they're going to be putting in levels
like this character with this weapon
that you've never had before
so they realize that the fun at that
point is less about showing you new
stuff
than giving you interesting variation on
what you've seen and that's a some
that's a thing you generally see in a
lot of games
obviously lots of games break that rule
mine do generally i tend to be much more
linear with my my asset revelation just
because it's indie and there's lots of
different expectations of a game for me
that's three hours long rather than a 20
hour
aaa um but yeah it's um it's a whole
thing like you definitely map that out
as a developer
it's interesting because that that feels
so
when i think about what the musical
equivalent to that might be
um just drop the ball on the end of the
song
that exactly or the end of the game like
you know i think of
i think my mind immediately went
straight to um to final fantasy vii
remake because that was
an interesting case where some of the
music was you know
recorded big grand lush you know full
orchestra where they pulled out all the
stops and then there would be other cues
in the game that are that are all fake
and all synth orchestra because it's
like they just didn't have the resources
i guess to do everything so they had to
pick their best very few studios have
limitless resources and most of them
work at sony
um
but the interesting dilemma about that
is you know for example the big final
boss
one-winged angel sephiroth music that's
like one of
the most iconic pieces from a score that
is replete
with uh iconic pieces that
you would not skimp on that and but it's
your grand finale
which means that some vanishing or maybe
not vanishing but you know some
some knowing subset of players will not
get
to that point and yet it is so beloved
so it's an interesting song
i mean we don't do it with writing
either we're not like they're not going
to get to the end so
who cares
look at the original bioshock that has
like build up build up build it build it
build a build up and then 15 second
ending cutscene
you know like like it it is but that's
because the truth
writing it's still sorry that's not
right
schedule is not about effort per asset
it's about the frequency of the assets
you deliver
so you're still writing you still want
to write a good ending but i guarantee
in something like spider-man or any kind
of um
insert sony first-party single-player
campaign here
presumably hey um most of the writing
for like box and shout outs like he's
over there
reloading those kind of this the stuff
thank you thank you i could do this wake
up craig miller you've got more
competition
majority of the writing that is actually
going to be in the game with you for the
whole game
will 100 be scheduled up so that you've
heard
most of those those barks in the first
half of the game
and you'll hear that when you play the
game most games when you play them
you're hearing by i mean i've just i
just played miles per hour it's like by
the second half of that game
i've heard them say that yell the same
things to you as a player quite a few
times
moments and that's what makes it
excellent but there's still yeah it's
all about efforts about where you really
but i specifically mentioned
polish being like yeah that's that's the
thing that's that's pinging with me
tinging with me too i and alana brings
up a very solid point
you can start reusing assets but you
can't reuse writing
there's a difference between writing
dialogue and writing structure you can't
go
ah let's just recycle that too so i mean
you're writing must have been the wind
like there's those kind of black
the bulk of video game writing is box
and like and like
agreed the stuff that's said by
characters and that's not a
disparagement that's just literally the
text
right it's it it is all about in terms
of like skype systemic dialogue like if
you look at something
what was it uh i think it was guinness
book of records was knights of the old
republic um
or star wars the old republic tor was
was like the the largest script ever and
david cage just tried his best to beat
that but
um the the the thing that
i don't understand is
how do you the the brilliance of being
able to go
hey guys we understand that
these assets are going to fall into this
part of our game
therefore we know that they're going to
fall outside of that 30
completion rate therefore spend less
time on that
is projecting so far that's like someone
going episode 23
is going to be of season four we're not
going to have the same amount of budget
for so let's automatically make that a
an episode or like a bottle episode
now let's go shoot the pilot that's
bananas to me to be able to think
that's what you've got to do managing a
project like that's your job if you're
if you're putting together a project
also who doesn't usually hear
who does that fall in who's under who's
my scale it's me
triple a those brilliant production
managers who who are meant to be
handling that and it's what
and crucially i think the big thing here
to remember is how iterative these
processes are so it's not the case
we're not we're not talking here about
like not bothering with something we're
talking about not iterating on it more
than a couple of times so
everything's done on this and
everybody's shift over to here because
the the win
so you say okay we've got everything
done we've yeah we've got we've done
we've done
everything is okay now where do we spend
our time i remember this
mass effect andromeda because mass
effect andromeda
a lot of those facial animation issues
that people had problems with
were iteration issues they they were
basically this was said later by the
team choices gone out shot entirely it
was said later by the team
that uh that those a lot of the facial
animations that people didn't like those
those were like the first past
it's okay it's good enough we have to
come back and fix this and then they
just didn't have time and resources to
go back and fix that it's funny because
that's how games are made in that kind
of repetitive
iterative you get everything on the page
it's okay
and then you choose where you're gonna
spend more time bringing everything
there's a lot of the same term resident
evil 8 that's all i'm saying a lot of
the same boot
everywhere there's a there's a craft to
that there's a craft to knowing where
you can do that
you can't do that there's a term that
you mentioned the boot the back you
notice the boot
indicates the boot was not the best
thing that they probably should have is
there a toilet in residence
yes there is there's a you use it
[Laughter]
there's a term that uh
always comes up um that is always funny
because it's such a specific acronym
um that uh mvp
um that uh that uh
always you know minimum viable product
is the uh
term that that i is often brought
up in very early planning conversations
of like what's
what is the least we can ship this with
if it comes down to it if we find
ourselves running behind if we had a
if we had a big thing that hijacked the
schedule for you know six months and we
lost polish time that we're banking on
like
every project at least that i've been on
by and large has
um had a buffer zone at the end which is
this amorphous grab bag
period that's it's almost like this
contingency fund that you just are
getting the closer you get to that date
the less time there is to
in that because you're eating that
window as you get closer to it
and if that goes that's crunch usually
in fact yeah theoretically speaking
that's where i can go wrong
yeah yeah and so the idea being that
the idea being that like you always i i
am often tasked with the question of you
know what would be the
the mvp on the score you know if we if
we have
this amount of music that we need to
write that we've budgeted this amount of
you know time frame on but then we also
have these
production needs that we're trying to
meet like we need to go
to london to record orchestra or
whatever um
then the the the sort of finding where
everything can click together
and know what's the least i can can
guarantee you now the nice thing is
usually i'm i'm basically left to my own
devices
you can't really just add another song
in can you
how would that work in terms of like
where do you put it
it depends on how well conceived the
whole thing is like in how thoroughly
mapped out it is because sometimes
sometimes you make discoveries as you go
you know where you realize like like
like
i'll make up an example that's that's it
is truly made up but it's plausible like
look at an assassin's creed type game we
mapped it out so that there was a lot of
different logic behind the open world
combat music so that there would be
minimal amounts of repetition as you
just randomly got into fights on the
street separate from
scripted missions and things like that
and
but let's say we hadn't done that and
there was just like a bank of
combat music that was being randomly
pulled which is kind of
or or purely geographic which is kind of
the old school mmo or rpg you know like
here's the fight music for the forest
and here's the
music for the castle and here's the
whatever let's say we had done it that
way
um well you know play testing the game
as we're getting
to you know near the end i've had
analogous situations where i'm i go
boy i'm hearing you know this one
particular queue a lot
i really think we need more in that in
that bucket because god damn i'm i'm
sick of it and i'm just playtesting the
game and i wrote the [ __ ] thing
like imagine a player that's more into
this game than i am yeah so sometimes we
are making
late stage editions now it depends on
the contract not to to drag this into
that conversation but there
most especially on the aaa level most
contracts are
are worked out based on a on a
essentially a rate or a fee per minute
of music you deliver
so you can't just arbitrarily add more
music you have to discuss that because
they
they are bound to pay you for it uh
and so you know and i've i've tried i've
i hate that for the record i i hate that
approach
um i don't like that as a as a con as a
contractual
architecture but um it's also just that
it's just a fact of life that i've had
to accept
and part of the reason why i don't like
it is for the exact reason we're talking
about like creative reasons i'm playing
the game and i'm going the game is
suffering
because there's 90 minutes of music and
it could really use even just another 10
minutes of music what's the difference
at 90 to 100 like
i i can do it and and it's like well we
don't have that budgeted
and it's like do you feel though that
for whatever reason right or wrong that
music specifically is one of those
line-item things that kind of gets
dropped down to be like we can cut it or
we can
scale it back like do you feel like it's
it's considered more
of a soft asset versus like we
must have we must meet a certain
um lod on on this and so that's going to
gain more money or you know require more
resources
do you feel like you kind of get skipped
on i think
yeah i get the spirit of what you're
asking and the and it depends what
there's no consistent answer to that
because different studios are just all
over the place
same with writing depends on this is it
yeah but i think writing is more
understood
in general by the people making
spreadsheets to work out the budgets
music
but what's the difference most people
can't tell that i can't tell that was
that was recorded at
abbey road versus in the box well and
also the added the added question of
usually
usually they'll just my gut i shouldn't
say i shouldn't
make it sound like i'm offering an
authoritative diagnosis on how the
industry operates here because are you a
scientist
it's more of my uh it's more of my
instinct
uh it's it's this is sort of my informed
gut instinct that
i have a suspicion that a lot of
projects are budgeted where they you
know like let's say
it's a massive aaa game they'll have
thrown
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars potentially
into their music budget and it'll just
be whereas
the writing budget may be here's how
many lines
how many writers broken down to you know
side quests and main quests or whatever
here's how many days in the studio will
that will translate to with actors they
may already have their mind figured out
they won't have a clue
about any of the corollary so music will
just be one line on the spreadsheet
i'm assuming this i'm not drawing this
from experience but
i suspect it's like ah so then what
happens is okay they come to a composer
the
composer
says well i want to charge you x dollars
per minute and if they really want that
composer
then they basically just go and say well
let's divide our budget by that
amount and see how many minutes our
score gets to be now and so it's
so it's like that whereas you know in a
film for example
it's obviously the parameters are wildly
different but you sit down in a film and
you say okay well the movie's two hours
which means at maximum we have two hours
of score
there is no world in which we are
delivering
finished more than two hours of music we
might have considerably less so
it always is just what's your fee to do
this job and whatever the final number
is is whatever it is
now they have the luxury of very closed
parameters compared to the openness of a
lot of games especially big
systemic very you know open world that
kind of thing big aaa games but
the idea that the number would dictate
how much score you get and i i speaking
of mass effect
i think that that's an example where i i
would bet money that something along
those lines is what happened because
that game especially the first one was
very obviously
really ambitious for its budget because
the game is
reaching really hard in a lot of
different ways but it was you know
sci-fi rpg with a with this you know it
was doing the
plus and cover shooter yeah yeah well
the action rpg thing was pretty novel in
2007 like the idea of we're a full-on
rpg with dialogue trees and you know all
the kind of
dragon agey bioware kind of stuff but
we're a full-on action game too yeah
um the uh they clearly refined through
the games i mean the action in mass
effect 3 is actually quite good in the
first game it's
still pretty bad i tend to if i ever
replay that first game i play it on easy
yeah i mean that that happened no
judgment no judgment but they
point point being they reuse score
like crazy and it drive it always drove
me crazy it always wrote me that's like
for example there's
one piece this like kind of sentimental
piano piece whenever you open up one of
the romance subplots and it's just like
you know you click the dialogue you're
being moody you know
you're like you know play some romance
music
you'll be in like your your generic uh
like normandy
you know kind of van gaalis uh hobby
stuff and uh then they press the romance
button
and then you yeah like you'll be in
dialogue and and when you when you
clearly have the
the choice between is there is if you've
got a keyboard as well sorry austin have
you got a keyboard as well
no i think someone said romeo get some
duets
truck but i don't know who it came from
what did they try i missed it
it syncs perfectly with your finger
going down that's what it was romance
that's what i sound like
let's make love well in any case
[Music]
well then it's perfectly scored to your
way of living that's for sure then
the uh the um the uh
uh i love i like picture you and pam
sitting and talking and like in your
mind is the dialogue wheel and if you
don't choose something you'll both just
stand there and stare indefinitely
until until you choose what to say kind
of like our wedding night it was real
and she's just
she's just yeah a little animation who
goes first what happens now
sorry go ahead i'll shut up but yeah the
uh the um it did always drive me insane
that that
you know you'll be in this moody thing
but then there's the very transparently
obvious if i choose this
shepard is you know cracking open the
seal on oh there's
the the caden romance thread and the
music just does this
hard left turn into like full-on romance
very good oh it's so i feel like the
sims does that obviously but in a way
that's funny and i think
um resident evil 8 actually does it in a
way that uh any time there
isn't music in resident evil 8 i'm like
oh [ __ ]
and i started paying attention to it uh
there's a lot of uh aspects of the
design of r8 that i think are really
interesting but i started paying
attention to when there's no sound to
see if it happens every time
but they do make it pretty unpredictable
sometimes there's no music and nothing
bad is going to happen and sometimes
it's going to be terrifying
in a way that is so unsettling that is
dead space that's true dude dead space
said that the best i feel like they were
the
like the bar setter whatever
for that like i i still to that day can
refer to that and
just like i i brought it up you're like
yep exactly that ugh
but mass effect has this really
interesting thing with the music where i
saw somebody tweet this the other day
and i was like you're absolutely right
where the nostalgia that i have for mass
effect 1
is very much tied to the music
so when i think of mass effect 1 i think
of that map room
music or the galaxy map music more than
anything else so even though i want to
know something crazy
sure that piece was verbatim the demo
that sam hewlett wrote for that game
i did i did a game maker notebook with
jack wall who was kind of the main
composer of those scores but he brought
in uh
he brought in uh uh sam and when sam was
asked to demo the piece that he wrote
is called uncharted worlds and it was
literally just his demo to get the gig
is
basically the most popular piece from
the whole first year that happens a lot
like that genuinely like the the the
demo track being specifically the
the menu music is something that like
thomas was alone
our menu music is dave's demo our next
next game
that we've i just got the demo from the
composer that that's going to be scoring
next next game it's going to be
the next next game that's that's going
to be the menu music because it's just
yeah it's there's something about i
don't know
there's like a tentativeness i have a
question so is that
because you know what demo love is
i think everybody gets it where
specifically like with musicians
um any time that like whenever we were
like when we were recording our album
whatever i would be like can you just
burn me off a rough mix i want to i want
to listen to that they're like nope i
was like
well i want to listen to it they said no
because we don't want you to fall in
love with it because it's not finished
yet
and the problem is is that you'll get so
attached even though this isn't the
finished product and even though this is
not perfect
even though it's going to get better you
will hear the better version and then it
will just like
alana's talking about where it's like
you get this nostalgia
that you see the lens through you're
like well where's that thing where it's
it's not doing this and you actually
fall in love because we all water seeks
its own level and we will
find a way to adapt to it so is it
because that would happen all the time
is that the first is the reason why
you're like put that in is because
that's the first piece of music that you
got
and you're like throw this in the very
first or is it because
well that doesn't that definitely
doesn't apply in the case of mass effect
because that piece like it's it's not
the menu
uh you know it's a menu of sorts it's a
menu dude
come on now yeah but well fair enough
but i think it was i think it was
moving a curse around it's a menu well i
should say it's not the whole
script yeah i know what you mean no it's
not the home screen that's true that's a
different piece
um i think it's i think it's more the
from my perspective at least and to be
clear like not the demo wouldn't be the
one that goes in obviously there'll be a
better version of that but i think the
um
i think it's also just the objectives of
someone who's doing whether when a
composer is doing you like a debt
whether when composers pitching
basically
i feel like austin you'll know this
better than me but what it feels like to
me when i receive these
demos is it's usually that they're
trying to
really get to kind of the is the essence
the the most
core thing they can they they want to
show me that they know the world that
they're writing music for
and there's kind of that essential
element to it which then in a menu for
me a menu
a good menu track should be doing the
same thing it should be the essence it's
the
it's the framing it's the it's the smell
when you enter the theater it's kind of
the the
the baseline you're going to be building
what is um so i think maybe it's the
same objective
is that how often do they get
down into a theater what do i even mean
by that like the overture
like groups of people i guess i guess i
meant overchip i said
smell which is a really interesting
let's say popcorn cognition
we'll go we'll go with the both very
charitable it's like rooms full of
people taking their coats off it smells
great though sorry go on troy
is that how often do i mean in fairness
you haven't smelled that in over a year
so you're
you're probably mythologizing i walked i
walked past someone in the street the
other day
and i smelt like someone's bo for the
first time because i almost cried
i was like this is amazing i'm missing
people so fast
in a hotel for 14 days but it's so close
to like just
how often do they get that right well
you're like well
i mean it can happen to everyone at some
point you know we will where they go
that we because that demo that they're
doing that's before they get the gig
that is essentially their audition
right so it's i i suppose it's
it's not too difficult if they get it
right they get the job it's like a it's
like a
it's a survivor bias right
is it so are you saying like because
they got the job then then
you kind of come to them a little bit if
if that was
like does it change your mind or do you
or if you're like yeah okay i'm gonna
use you
for example austin gives you his take of
what on a new ip
right so there is no estab you're not
like i'm going for star trek i'm not
going for star wars or i'm going for
mass effect
it's like this is a brand new world
brand new thing we're trying to be
really
cutting edge and you just blindly send
out a demo
and you go based on what i know about
you and
and whatever you know intuitive things
you're trying to pull from
you present something and how often
what i guess i'm what i'm really asking
is if you choose that person
do you then go well now my world looks a
little bit like what they
i'm seeing the world a little bit
through their lens okay it's like an
audition like if an actor walks in and
does something you weren't expecting
i i very rare i would never cast an
actor and the one time i've done this
i've regretted it
um i would never cast no no not try
baker i've never cast an actor
with a with an audition where they've
done like an accent and then
told them to do a different accent later
in the process
when that statement is true is because i
didn't audition for john
he didn't audition for me so that's the
only reason why because i came in i was
like
maybe we should be talking like this
he's like nope all right yeah all right
cool
that's true that's true but like but
like no but seriously like you it's
casting it's good casting hiring people
for a project is good casting so you're
looking for people who
give you what you want but then ideally
as well kind of give you something
that's beyond what you want so from my
perspective
yeah if i'm hiring someone to be
especially with a composer because music
is like
probably my weakest area of expertise in
terms of every director feels that way
by the way ever i hear that
basically 99 of projects the first thing
i'm told is now
bear in mind i don't really know how to
talk about music or i don't know
anything about music and honestly the
really difficult jobs are the one
percent where they're like
i know everything about music i know
everything about music i love flat and
can we use this instrument
but i'm not hiring i'm not hiring i
think this is again is a
perception issue kind of outside of our
fields where
i think people think you hire people um
just for the product of the work they do
so you hire austin because you need
music yes that's true but you also hire
austin because you need an expert on
what the music should be
so you're also hiring smart people no
alarms i would never
never hire austin which is why i asked
him to do this podcast
welcome everybody but like it's just a
conciliatory prize
you know you're like you can do the
podcast in exchange for never ever ever
having outside professional
opportunities
yeah i never want to be in the same room
as you in a business context
i can definitely speak to this
whole subject uh that checks out the
there
that makes sense you obviously i suppose
we would hire you for this subject yeah
so because i've had it both ways for
example on the banner saga
they were like you're here in the exact
spirit that you just described mike
anytime i said now what do you think
i have this notion that combat could be
done like that you know that for those
unaware the game has a very like slow
pace methodical turn-based strategy
sort of vibe to its combat it's
intentionally very deliberately paced
and
and slow and so you know i pitched a
similarly very slow kind of funeral
durge approach to the music
even though it's big viking inspired
characters smashing each other's shields
and hammers i said you know this should
feel world weary
i think it should feel like they are
they take no pleasure in this
and they they have no bloodlust this is
this is a tragic battle every time
because they just
are tired and i said what do you think
and they go well
if you're sold like you you
are the head of your own department so
you have to convince yourself
uh so if you if you feel that that's the
approach
you know obviously if i did something
that they if i came back and said i
think it should all be
you know yeah exactly like i think it
should be just pure k-pop
they'll be like well that's a little at
odds with the rest of the vision of the
game
uh let's hear it like but let's yeah
they would they would hear it and they
would listen charitably through the lens
of
like is there something to this not from
a defensive posture of i'm pretty sure
this isn't going to work
and like listening to that filter but
i've had other projects that are
that are definitely not that vibe
they're like we have a very we have a
pretty specific idea of what we think
this needs
and so can you deliver that and demos or
auditions
fit anywhere in this spectrum where
sometimes it's
here's what we're looking for and we
want to know can you do this
i'm in the middle of working on a demo i
wish i could talk about it right now
because it'd be so
it'd be so illustrative of what we're
talking about where where they said you
know
in fact they initially explicitly said
we don't think
you are the right fit because we've
never heard you do this kind of music
and i said well all them better reason
to let me demo yeah exactly
watch this [ __ ] yeah i said it's no it's
no commitment
it's no commitment you don't have to all
you have to do is say no if you
hit play and then four minutes later go
nah not for me
not for nothing though there is a
inherent cost not only a lot of times in
yours
in your case with dollars but also time
so it's like hey
it's no skin off my teeth you know to to
for me to do this i'm like
depends i've seen you work and you spend
you'll spend days weeks coming up with
a a demo an audition
and you'll employ a 60-piece orchestra
and incur all of that cost and then at
the end of it you're crossing your
fingers going
well hope this worked and you can i mean
what maybe a couple of months or many
many times
it's not you can do it you have an
album's worth of material
that you can do that's bananas to me
i don't me it's like i don't know i'll
do an audition through it i was like you
auditioned for this
you know two months ago and they want to
make now give you dollars for it i'm
like oh okay
no i feel like some like acting audition
stuff seems pretty brutal to me where
they're like hey
uh you got this this morning um it's 10
pages we need it by tomorrow thank you
and they often don't even get back to
people it's never
brutal but they're still making you do
your work
which is a craft that you're an expert
in completely for free
often without even responding to you
when you've submitted it i still feel
like acting auditions are pretty rough
sometimes i'm like it seems
to me the part that's to me the worst
part of acting auditions which we have
our own version of but i think it's
i think it's harder for actors is the
lack of
especially on triple a games the lack of
awareness of how
these lines fit into anything and the
fact that you don't know
there's so often you don't know anything
about the game at all
and and you know it's one thing as a
composer
to be told like look here's the broad
brushstrokes of what we're after you
know my hope is always that the
the demo slash audition reads as a
conversation starter
and it an ideal situation is where they
hear it and they go
you don't have the burden of writing the
definitive version of this theme of this
piece of our game
right now we want to know your thought
process and how you're approaching it
so that it feels like down that road
lies the answer
i had this my agent the other day did a
little thought exercise on facebook
where he asked a bunch of composers
what's the best quote you've ever gotten
from somebody that worked with you and
so everybody
was was uh my favorite was hanz zimmer
responded
and said uh this is better than sex with
some director quote he wouldn't tell
he wouldn't say what director told him
that but uh i mean i'm gonna go look
like i'm gonna go nolan but uh but my my
my response was was in response to an
audition for a job that i got where the
director said
um this is this they said it was for a
movie
and they sent me a scene and i said can
i watch the whole movie and then i'll do
the scene it was basically the opening
scene so i watched the whole movie
loved the movie then i wrote this really
and i'm really glad i did because where
the movie ends up has this plot twist
that i thought oh i can foreshadow that
in the score and i would if i'd watched
the opening in isolation i would have
had no idea so i did this whole pitch
around here's the
weird subverted subversive way that i'm
going to force out
foreshadow the ending in a way that
you'll never track but
then pays off and i wrote this elaborate
thing i hired musicians and singers and
all kinds of stuff
and i remember sent to the director and
he goes this is completely wrong for the
scene
but only someone crazy enough to try
this should be working on this film so
you're hired
and i was like that's i'm putting that
on my business card man that's that's
the best
the best
austin and this is one of my favorite
quotes and i've i've
totally stolen it and applied to my
conversations in the way that i do my
business which is
i'm not selling the end product what i
am selling is the process by which
together we will get there
like what i want to do is i don't hope
that i walk in the door and get it right
now most directors don't want to hear
that because what they want the
shortcut you want i know but the the
thing is if
i walk and i go i know inherently who
this character is i know them
inside and out there's nobody that can
play this role than i
a director may appreciate that passion
and that that fervor
but how can i know inside and out who
this character is
off of one scene maybe two if i watch
it's also selfish
sorry it is it's 100 selfish and what i
want to do is i mean it's selfish on my
part
why would i because if i was
content to you know be
type like let's say that that after
journey came out
all i ever wanted to do was continue
writing music that sounded exactly like
journey
it would be pretty easy from that point
because then it's like oh if we want
that
we just bring him in we turn him loose
we don't have to have a meeting we don't
have to have a conversation
just have him do that again and if if
that was satisfying to me
great life's kind of on autopilot at
that point and i i can i can do my music
and then do other things with my life
but because my interest is so
specifically
in getting to the end of a project and
saying my little catch phrases
when we ship the last cue over the line
i i want to look back and go i didn't
know that i knew how to do any of this
yeah dude like i and and so what that
requires though is
the director buying in on the fact that
this will be a process because i myself
don't even know where we're going to end
up ideally
and but that's but that's an x factor
that's not i want to be scared the
entire
time but i want to do it without fear i
want to be scared the entire time going
i don't know if i can do this i don't
know if i can do this i don't know if i
can do this
but be able to be fearless in that that
to me is
to be able to have that kind of
perspective on the other side of it
and not every not every not every
project you know to mike's point i think
if i
if i can paraphrase you the
some for some directors or maybe not in
general but like within specific
departments like maybe you
love this thing that we're describing
with actors because you've got a soft
spot for that process or you resonate
with it you understand it you feel like
you're an effective director in that
space but when it comes to music
i mean on john wick you were you were
not really micro managing
at all it was basically like once we
kind of had the vibe
figured out i remember we we it took us
a little while to get
to the what we wanted to do i remember
lots of back and forth between us on
that but then yeah once we had
this is what we're doing go for it yeah
exactly yeah which seemed like that's
your happy place right like
like i
and then i like things to like go in a
very logical way after that because that
just makes it easier to schedule and
make sure that things hit their marks
you know
from a production point of view i don't
have to make the last half of the game
[ __ ] in order to fund the first half of
the game right
yeah that's full circle you know right
which is always a trade-off
return was great by the way we didn't
talk about it that is what i tried to
lead into here
can i let me introduce the show real
quick hey everyone welcome to play watch
listen i'm a little pierce i'm a video
game right now that's
that's austin wintery he's a video i can
propose that's max walker
he's a video game actor and that is mike
bithell he's a video game director i
didn't even know i didn't even catch the
max walker thing
yeah there you go um i'm gonna start
with austin please be short
austin how are you liking mass effect
it's easy to be short i've barely had a
chance to play it to be honest i've been
so slammed so
perfect great yeah i mean i i've always
loved it
i threw on some support swag for this
i'm actually boiling because i don't
normally
wear things that don't have a zipper in
the front so i'm literally exploding
just for the brand take it off i played
a little really narrow neck
it's gonna be a whole process to get
this thing off i played a little bit of
the mass effect trilogy
uh remastered legendary edition whatever
um and yeah i'm like cool it's mass
effect that's chill like i'm happy that
it exists
that's my take um but i was expecting
some more i was expecting i'll just add
i'm being brief for me this is brief i
uh i saw your i saw your gym look
uh the um the thing there were some
there's some quality of life changes
that they made
in the second and third that were really
basic that i thought that they would
just go ahead and do in the first one i
thought was part of the point for
example
when you are going around different
solar systems and scanning from
resources and stuff
they i think can't remember if it was in
two or it was only in three they put a
little percentage complete
thing for you to know like i've explored
everywhere
and mass effect 1 does not do that and
it's just up to you to remember or to
revisit old locations
yeah and that's especially annoying when
you go you clear out a whole solar
system
and then later you unlock a quest that
adds a location there
you have to you have to kind of know
what you're doing and
and yeah and that that that's like a
little
quality of life thing that all they have
to do is just add a little percentage
argus row 89 yeah i thought that they
were going to do more stuff like that to
kind of
retcon the first one to be more like the
second and third they really like they
changed anything at all
yeah which yeah i was gonna do a star
trek deep cut and i was gonna be like
scanning for life forms
[Laughter]
doing picard right now i have to go he's
about to go characters evolving i
came in late and i'm leaving i have to
go also you have to tell me what you
think of fraternal before i let you
leave i will
oh my god that opening cut scene is
dope it's really good all right
okay well that's uh that's our final
episode that i don't know
that's on fire i will say this i make a
proclamation i'm not going to return
i'm not going to last jedi this i'm
going to i'm going to not not not jeddah
safe system in hey guys i know the house
smart guys i want to bully them into
again the safe system though the very
beginning you're like you want to set
your
set your display you want to do all this
stuff can you see how this is barely
visible this game is hard
it's supposed to be hard it's like oh
that's not a good sign it is pretty hard
how do i
all right maybe we'll revisit it next
week i was really hoping
it's a really good internal watch listen
here we are
just didn't work out um i don't know
what i expected i will endeavor to play
it but
you should i think it's fantastic i'm a
big fan but i also really do love
resident evil and can talk about that
forever but i don't know if any of you
have played it so
all right nope cool thanks for watching
everybody we'll see you next week